توقع المزيد من الوحشيه من قبل روسيا في
الايام المقبله خشيه عبر عنها الرئيس
الاوكراني فولدومرزيلانسكي بعد ان حذر
منها هجمات روسيه على البنيه التحتيه
ستستمر حتى تنفذ الصواريخ من موسكو بحسب
تعبيره لكنه في ذات الوقت قال ان اوكرانيا
مستعده لتلك الهجمات
المضاده وهي اجراءات اكثر قوه درسنا مساله
لا تزود الجيش بمعدات وذخائر جديده وعقدت
اجتماعا منفصلا حول قضايا متعلقه
هناك حلول لمنع روسيا من اي فرصه للتلاعب
بالحياه الداخليه
روسيا كانت قد اعلنت هذا الاربعاء انها
سيطرت على ثلاث بلدات بالقرب من مدينه
بخمود مدمره بشكل كبير في شرق اوكرانيا
مدينه تحاول القوه الروسيه الاستيلاء
عليها منذ الصيف الماضي ما دفع بسكان
البلدات الى الفرار من بيوتهم
ليلا ونهارا الصواريخ تسقط بالقرب من
المنازل وتحطم النوافذ
ولم يبقى شيء الامر صعب للغايه
هذه المعارك الاخيره تكتسي اهميه رمزيه
بالنسبه للروسي اذ ان الاستيلاء على مدينه
بخموس سلسله الهزائم الروسيه والتي تمثلت
اساسا في انسحاب القوه الروسيه من خاركيف
ويخرسون بعد استماته الاوكرانيين في
القتال والدعم الغربي للقوات الاوكرانيه
دعم سيتعزز ربما في الايام المقبله بامداد
واشنطن كيف بقنا بلا دقيقه توجيه